hello we're glad you joined us for this
live webinar obtaining samples for
precision medicine studies use an
outsider's perspective I am Christina
mahalik of labyrinth and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
libraries the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars inducing
scientific collaboration and learning to
learn more visit labrys com let's get
started you proposed questions to the
speaker during the presentation while
they're fresh in your mind to do so
simply type them in the Q&A box which
will open when you click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of the
presentation window questions will be
answered at the end of the presentation
to enlarge this slide window click on
the screen icon in the lower right hand
corner of the slide window if you
experience technical problems seeing or
hearing the presentation just click on
the support button sounds at the top
right of the presentation window or
report your problems by clicking on the
green at Q&A button at the lower left of
the screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credit after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located in the bottom left-hand corner
of the web page and follow the process
of painting your credit it is now my
pleasure to introduce today's speaker
Matt clusive chief commercial officer I
may speak max with occlusive series as
chief commercial officer at IVC he leads
the Amba speak sales marketing business
development
and customer service functions prior to
joining on the seat Matt was most
recently at thermo fisher scientific
where he led a business focusing on
large-scale deployment of genetic
analysis technologies including
next-generation be in a sequencing
capillary electrophoresis sequencing
qpcr and other technologies part is to
thermo fisher scientific Matt held
management roles at the american type
culture collection life technologies in
the kinsey in town that is published in
the Journal of commercial science
technology and the McKinsey quarterly
and the credit union journal in 2015
Illinois State University so I could end
a young alumni of the year he research
receipts and in a seat in economic
history from the London School of
Economics and two BS in the
communication from the Illinois State
University the often studied at maudlin
College University of Oxford mr. closest
will now begin his presentation the
floor is yours thank you very much it's
a pleasure to join you today again my
name is maya closest i'm the chief
commercial officer at omni seek quick
disclaimer before we begin the opinions
expressed here represent my own and not
those of on the seat there's some
additional disclosure language there in
the bike bottom right hand corner of
this slide as you need more information
i'm very pleased today to speak to you
about a challenge for precision medicine
that i think is very present and and
very important for the field to address
over the coming years if we're to
realize the vision of precision medicine
that we hold as an industry
so today well i'll be speaking to you
about is obtaining samples for precision
medicine studies i've called it an
outsider's perspective because i'm
relatively new to this challenge of
trying to obtain samples and many of
these insights are from my perspective
as someone who has experience in the
life science tools space as well as
someone who has experience recently in
the clinical space so with that we'll go
ahead and move into a brief introduction
of myself I appreciated the introduction
just a few moments ago I've really been
in two industries in my career financial
services and life science tools and more
recently at Omni seek really in the
clinical molecular diagnostic space you
can see a host of different institutions
I've been with on the left-hand side
please forgive the photograph it's it's
probably the best I can do so that's
okay a little information about Omni
seek on the right hand side on me seek
is a subsidiary of the roswell park
cancer institute in Buffalo New York
Roswell Park was the United States first
comprehensive cancer institute the
organization is essentially a spin out
of the molecular pathology lab we offer
a variety of New York State Club
approved assays both next-generation
sequencing siiii and other platforms the
company's mission is very much aligned
with the the broad goal of precision
medicine today that is to try to find
the right drug or the right trial for
every patient and as we go through the
rest of this presentation I'll think I
think you'll see how our endeavors are
really aligned with what the challenges
that we're discussing today for
precision medicine moving forward
[Music]
I want to start off by discussing some
of the different objectives of life
science tool companies versus clinical
companies and this will specifically be
in in the space of molecular diagnostics
so now that I have experience in both of
these arenas it's it's very interesting
to compare and contrast where these
organizations lineup and certainly where
they differ so on the left hand side the
main purpose of a life science tools
company is to produce instruments and
reagents that can be used by the
community for both research and clinical
purposes the clinical market in a lot of
these cases is relatively nascent
especially on the next generation DNA
sequencing side other sides like mass
spectrometry qpcr real-time pcr these
technologies have been in the clinic for
for some time but sequencing is truly a
revolution but it's already swept
through the research arena and is now
making its way to the clinic these
companies also focus on certain
regulatory markings such as fda approval
in the united states CEI VD approval in
europe and and other markings in China
and other countries primarily though I
think one of the main differences from
the next segment we'll talk about is
that these companies are focused on
businesses to produce these materials
distribute them and ensure customer
satisfaction and so they are organized
to that purpose on the flip side as we
look at clinical companies they have
different objectives in mind so first
for any assay that a molecular
diagnostics company produces they
typically have to demonstrate analytical
validity clinical validity which is
demonstrated by the two sub points i
have there a retrospective study and a
prospective clinical trial and then the
ultimate goal is to be incorporated into
guidelines such as nccn and others that
ultimately lead to these assays
being included in the standard of care
now I've drawn two arrows on this slide
because I do think there are some
similarities but yet some differences
between these so analytical validity for
clinical companies is really
demonstrating that the technology and
the assay itself is doing what it is
that the the company is claiming it does
that is very similar to what life
science tool companies have to do in
terms of ensuring to the to the market
that their platforms are accurate and
the reagents are robustly manufactured
in a consistent fashion however there is
a slight variation there that I think
you can see and then secondly for
clinical validation this is similar to
an FDA approval or CEI VD marking
however the hurdles to go through that
process are different typically for FDA
approval for example you'll go ahead and
get the platform approved with one a say
in particular in mind and then the FDA
approvals can follow from that CI VD
markings in Europe have a slightly lower
bar which is why many life science tool
companies start with cee IBD approvals
and then move from there but it is very
similar on the clinical space to the to
the clinical validation but the the
robustness of the study has a different
focus and a different rigor to it for
clinical companies moving on I'd like to
just very briefly talk to you about the
experience that I'll speak to here and
that was our efforts at Omni seek to
develop a retrospective study for an
assay we're calling on ec community
bands as many of you probably know the
immune checkpoint and immunotherapy
space and cancer is revolutionary in
terms of patient care as opposed to
targeted therapy where you're talking
about responses that are perhaps in some
cases several 6-12 months relative to a
chemotherapy treatment on a kaplan-meier
curve with these immunotherapies were
actually
talking about durable responses and that
is a very breathtaking advancement for
the field so this test uses five test
modalities you can see them on the right
hand side I won't walk through all of
them but what we have been trying to do
at Omni seek is develop a retrospective
study to validate this assay with the
proper guidelines and authorities moving
on let's really get into the need here
in terms of the topic that I'd like to
speak about today these retrospective
studies that are required for molecular
diagnostic companies to go ahead and
consider doing a prospective clinical
trial they require a lot of samples to
get a statistically significant
population you typically need to go
beyond one institution many companies
will have a good relationship with one
institution they may be a subsidiary or
may have an investor that actually is
you know a healthcare provider whether
this is a Cancer Center it could be a
comprehensive payer provider network
there are other means by which companies
will typically at least have a
relationship with one health care system
depending upon the size of that
healthcare system though it may be
necessary to go beyond that institution
in order to actually fill out the
required samples for a retrospective
study now the the number of variables
will have a resulting impact on the size
of the study that that you need to
conduct the typical rule of thumb is the
more variables that the assay is
interrogating the larger the sample size
needs to be in the retrospective study
so if you're only interrogating one
variable the the number of samples in
terms of a statistically significant
standard that journal
would be happy to accept will be a
little bit lower than if you have
multiple variables the ideal study then
will typically include anywhere from
several hundred to potentially thousands
of samples and there are examples of
successful molecular diagnostic
companies that frankly never stop
building their population in a
retrospective sense you can get into
semantics about whether once the assay
is released it's really a prospective
edition but nevertheless it's really
around collecting the proper reference
population to essentially validate the
use of the assay moving forward one of
the biggest challenges and I think this
is really where the rubber meets the
road on this issue is the significant
attrition that can be expected as one
goes about trying to obtain samples for
a retrospective study in our experience
and in the experience of others that
I've anecdotally surveyed on this topic
the attrition rate for actually pulling
in retrospective samples is very
significant and that's not only within a
single institution but as you look
across multiple institutions you can
expect anywhere from eighty percent plus
attrition from the number of samples
that are initially identified down to
the actual number of samples that
qualify for the study that you're
looking to conduct and so that in and of
itself creates a significant challenge
to getting these types of studies done
and then by extension actually producing
new innovations in the field of
precision medicine so some of the
impediments that that lead to the
significant attrition or possibly just a
challenge in terms of obtaining samples
at all really cut across all of the
different types of institutions that
you're likely to reach out to to obtain
these types of
simples I've listed three here and we'll
get into some more on a segment by
segment basis in just a moment but let's
focus on these first three so the first
is price per sample this is obviously a
budget constraint for many organizations
the challenge with molecular diagnostics
is that you're typically competing with
pharmaceutical companies these companies
will tend to spend anywhere from five to
ten perhaps even more on a per sample
basis for qualified samples that would
go into a prospective clinical trial as
you think about the number of samples
required for a molecular diagnostic
assay for most organizations that number
is going to be too high simply because
the economics of molecular diagnostics
is so much different than pharma just
for an example the lifetime value of a
pharmaceutical customer could easily be
in the six figures whereas for a
molecular diagnostic company the
lifetime value of a customer is probably
going to be in you know the low
five-figure range and that's assuming
that this provider is going to be
ordering a lot of tests over a several
year time span and so the differences in
those economics i think really then feed
into the budgets that a molecular
diagnostic company can offer relative to
a pharmaceutical company labor
availability is is the next significant
challenge when conducting a
retrospective study there are two
components that really come into play
first is identifying pulling preparing
and shipping the samples themselves and
the second component is around
collecting the data that goes with those
samples that will then feed into the
study so that's really two different
will call them labor pools that that
need to be tapped for obtaining samples
for a retrospective study in doing so
you tend to touch a lot of different
people within these types
institutions and I've listed some
examples here on the slide so
oncologists almost always have to be
involved but depending upon the nature
of the study you may be able to get away
with a research fellow or someone of
that nature radiologists are typically
required in so far as for rhesus
criteria you typically rely on stands to
measure disease progression and so
getting time from those folks is also
important as I mentioned in terms of
pulling samples you'll typically have
operations folks that are in banks that
you'll need to work with in terms of
actually pulling the samples themselves
preparing them for shipment making sure
that you're either obtaining the entire
block which is typically not the case or
you're obtaining a number of cuts lines
of you know various numbers to go ahead
and have those sent over for it for your
study and then finally you're competing
with the day-to-day operations of the
institution themselves and perhaps
competing studies those competing
studies can be investigator-initiated
studies within the institution itself
they can be pharmaceutical clinical
trials it really varies and then you
know everybody's busy on a day to day
basis so this tends to be to a certain
extent incremental work for these
institutions so labor is is really a key
challenge and we'll talk a little bit
later about some ways to ensure that you
are not asking too much on the labor
front that would actually put your
ability to obtain samples at risk
finally across all institutions is an
IRB process this question while it may
not emerge in the initial conversation
in my experience I would be comfortable
saying that almost in every case that
will come up at
point the interesting thing about this
is that for a non-interventional
retrospective study which is about the
lowest bar you can do in terms of of an
IRB approval the necessity for having an
independent IRB verification accepting
other institutions IRB approvals
formatting your own for for your
specific or the specific institution
that makes and for the examples there
tends to be amazing variability between
how institutions interpret the IRB
process relative to a study of this
nature so I as you progress and again
we'll talk a little bit later about some
of the strategies to to ensure success
this is an area where flexibility is
really key and that's the point I've
crawled out here at the bottom across
all three of these components one size
does not fit all the price per sample
you know will convey significantly
between institutions labor availability
to cutting back on the nature of the
institution will be significantly
variable and again the crb process is
likely to be variable as well so it's
very important to stay flexible to the
institutions that you're dealing with
and instead of trying to impose your
process and and your understanding of
the issue you really do need to do more
listening in these cases to respond to
the the protocols that they may have set
up the institutional guidelines and just
the general practices of the the
partnering institutions to make sure
that that you can obtain the samples
that you need other impediments are
segments specific and so what I've done
here is I've identified three different
segments that we'll talk about on the
next slide and we'll get specific on
each of these but in our experience you
can really divide up the typical
challenges
that you encounter with a retrospective
study by these three segments the first
one are your major academic medical
centers I've been specifics here not to
list specific names because I certainly
think that these issues cut across all
institutions within these segments and I
certainly didn't want to put one
institution on the spot so major
academic medical centers are our one
case you know there's there's probably
you know anywhere from let's say 10 to
25 maybe 30 of those across the United
States depending upon who you ask bio
banks are another source bio banks can
be attached to institutions they can be
independent there are some kind of
third-party bio banks out there that
have relationships with other bio banks
and can query them to pull together
samples the number of them tends to be
more than the major academic medical
centers but I would guess you're
probably not talking about more than 40
no more than probably 50 material bio
banks out there that could potentially
provide samples for a retrospective
study and then finally you have your mid
tier cancer institutes and your
community practices this is really the
bulk of where cancer is practiced across
the United States and I would venture in
other regions of the globe as well these
institutions in terms of number you know
you're well into the thousands mid-tier
cancer centers you're probably looking
somewhere in the hundreds community
practices are well into the thousands
let me cover the final point on this
slide down at the bottom round
experience so when it comes to these
types of studies you will see a lot of
variability across these three segments
major academic medical centers tend to
be the recipients of a lot of
pharmaceutical sponsored clinical trials
they tend to have a lot of experience
with things like reeses criteria a
valuable scans tissue in stored and
available in the types of way that are
required for retrospective studies they
have a lot of experience and I apologize
I've just realized that I didn't label
these Harvey bolts only a full Harvey
ball in this case means high and an open
circle or kind of that quarter moon that
I have there that means low in this case
so continuing on the experience bio
banks in our experience don't tend to
have surprisingly a lot of experience
with retrospective studies and this was
surprising because a lot of bio banks
will advertise that they are that they
are available for these types of studies
and they want to do these types of
studies but my hypothesis would be that
in most cases they are receiving
requests from researchers who are doing
research use only studies and don't have
enough experience at these times to to
really be able to respond to the to the
rigors of a clinical retrospective study
and so it's it's a little more
challenging to get these institutions
over the line and again we'll talk more
about from the specific issues with bio
banks in just a moment your mid-tier
Cancer Center is your community
practices you'll see a wide variety of
experience with these mid-tier cancer
centers will do prospective clinical
trials with pharmaceutical companies
typically not in the numbers you see at
the major academic medical centers but
they'll likely have some amount of
experience some community practices have
never attempted something like this in
the past and so you have a lot of
variability within that segment in terms
of experience gauging the experience of
a particular institution can be pretty
challenging but there are some probing
questions you can ask to get a sense for
what they've done in the past what
resources they have access to in order
to be able to complete a study of this
nature so it does help to to go into
those conversations with the
thought around probing on their
experience so you know exactly what type
of institution you're dealing with okay
moving on so there are a number of pros
and cons in terms of working with each
one of these segments and I want to be
sure to call out the pros because
although we're talking about challenges
with precision medicine I think it's
important to look for the light at the
end of the tunnel in these types of
studies and for those of you who have
not done them before i can say
comfortably from experience that the
process of doing these is is very
challenging and there will be a lot of
times where it seems like there is not a
light at the end of the tunnel but in
our experience there typically is it
will just take a lot longer than you'd
expect an otaku a little bit more about
that in just a second so let's let's go
through this slide so major academic
medical centers I've already touched on
on some of these points but because of
their experience with especially
pharmaceutical and
investigator-initiated clinical trials
they'll typically have very robust data
they'll typically have very well-managed
bio banks they will have a very high
interest in new research so if you're
offering a new molecular diagnostic
assay that is tapping into something
that is very current that is very
quote-unquote sexy at the moment you
should be able to attract quite a bit of
interest from these institutions and
finally a lot of these institutions
employ a lot of the key opinion leaders
that will be critical for supporting
this assay once it reaches the market
and so working with at least one or two
of these types of institutions is very
helpful because it not only sets the
groundwork for the retrospective in the
prospective trial but it also sets the
framework for market acceptance once the
is released the cons with working with
major academic medical centers I've
listed a few here probably the biggest
one I would say in our experience is
actually the second bullet under there
the separation between the oncologist
the clinicians and the pathology
department in some institutions you'll
see these two groups really working in
lockstep you know no room no separation
between them in other cases they it
seems as though they may be on different
planets and I really do mean this in in
kind of a joking sense but you will have
in some cases of pretty wide gulf
between an oncologist or a clinician
being very excited to participate in a
retrospective study and the motivations
and the desire for their pathology
colleagues to engage in the study in a
similar fashion it's probably the
largest one that we've seen another
significant one is is competing research
and the challenge around this one is
that you're not only talking about
competing research that's defined and in
process you're also talking at these
major academic medical centers about the
prospect for future research so in some
cases with these samples you're talking
about very precious samples that a
retrospective study of this nature would
go some way if not all the way too
exhausting the tissue available for
future studies and in some cases you
will encounter researchers who may not
have a particular objection to the study
you're proposing they may actually think
it's very interesting but they may not
be willing to part with those samples
simply because they want to preserve
them for a research study that they
would like to do some time in the future
it's a very difficult objection to
overcome but it is part of the reality
of dealing with these Institute's
shoes finally there's the institutional
bio major academic medical centers
almost entirely tend to be very large
institutions with quite a bit of
bureaucracy it's sometimes hard to find
out exactly who the decision-makers are
exactly the process for getting approval
to engage in a study of this nature in
some cases that may manifest in multiple
phone calls with multiple different
audiences and again this is where
patients really does come into play
let's talk a little bit about bio banks
so in terms of the pros with bio banks
they are set up in in such a way that
that should make them amenable for
retrospective studies they tend to
operate primarily on a fee-for-service
basis so as opposed to with the other
two segments where you're not only
trying to offer some kind of fee for
service arrangement but you're also
trying to get potential collaborators
excited about what you're doing and get
them involved in the study itself with
bio banks you kind of throw that out the
window you just focus on the
fee-for-service notion and you move from
that point because of that bio banks do
have the potential to move quickly in
terms of providing these samples and
getting them out the economics do tend
to to drive this segment so the old
mantra of cash is king does tend to come
into play however as we kind of
transition to the cons the the precise
requests for the samples themselves does
tend to play a pretty significant role
in the response that you'll get from bio
banks if it's an easy ask for the bio
bank in terms of both the samples and
the data that you're requesting you can
expect pretty quick turnaround if for
example though you're asking for quite a
bit of data you're asking for quite a
bit of a sample that can
can kind of put the brakes on the speed
with which bio banks will operate you do
tend to see a lot of variants within bio
banks in terms of the types of materials
they have available as well as the data
and and the challenge with both of these
is that with bio banks you tend to to
get what you see there's not a lot of
opportunity with most bio banks to go
back and for example obtain more tissue
which is very rare in any case but
especially on the data side there's very
limited opportunities with bio banks to
go back and pull more data simply
because the bio bank will typically
employ an operational staff you know
perhaps a business development function
but they don't tend to have
relationships in which they can go back
to an oncologist to a radiologist even
to a research fellow and get additional
information that you may need for a
study so that that in itself does create
a bit of a challenge where if you do
need additional information from a bio
bank you may be better off continuing
your search in other areas because the
likelihood of receiving that information
is not terribly high finally in terms of
mid-tier Cancer Institute's community
practices the nice things about working
with those institutions is that they
tend to have a more straightforward
decision making process it's easier to
identify who the decision maker is get
that person engaged and hopefully get
the approvals you need pretty quickly
they do also tend to have a very high
interest in publishing these
institutions are always looking for more
notoriety more publications that can
increase their stature possibly increase
their ability to attract government
funding or other kind of charitable
donations and and so that is a key
motivator for
for trying to sell these institutions on
participating in a retrospective study
on the con side similar to the body of
bank as I mentioned before you see a lot
of variability within this segment so
you will encounter some cases where
there are very limited additional
resources for data collection especially
when you start talking about community
practices one of the biggest challenges
is that the day-to-day operation itself
tends to overwhelm their ability to take
on a project like this and so again I
think minimizing your ask up front is is
is essential for for getting engagement
with these practices and finally
relative to the other two segments you
you will see quite a bit of variability
in terms of the potential number of
samples that these institutions might be
able to contribute to a study in our
experience you know you will be
surprised by some institutions who you
would never guess and they may have tens
to hundreds maybe even more in other
institutions that you'd expect that have
a lot you know then they only have a
dozen or a couple dozen something like
that so you've got to be prepared for
some pretty wide variability in terms of
the number of potential samples and then
as we talked about before it's always
important to factor in the attrition
rate into that so that you have an idea
of how many samples you're likely to end
up with at the end of the day okay so
what can requesters do to to increase
success we've talked about a lot of the
challenges we've talked about some of
the pros of dealing with each of these
segments and I've alluded to some points
on on this slide already but but let's
kind of walk through this in terms of
what are the things that your
institution can do when conducting a
retrospective study to maximize the
potential as you see in the center there
that you start getting samples in the
door because at the end of the day
that's the most important thing
I'm going to actually start on the
bottom right-hand portion of this slide
with the the legal and the economics I
think it's really important before you
have your first conversation to
internally amongst your institution
define what types of legal frameworks
you're going to use to to manage this
retrospective study and to agree on the
economic incentives early on with that
said my point around kind of flexibility
also comes into play here I would advise
having a very clear-cut hypothesis
within your institution before that
first conversation but I'd also advise
revisiting bad after your first handful
or so of conversations so that you can
gauge whether the hypothesis you had
before the first one is actually
resonating or whether you need to adjust
holding firm in really any of these
cases beyond the the kind of bare bones
of what you absolutely need and that
could be need in terms of budget costs
need in terms of sample requirements by
and large that is the worst thing you
can do for trying to successfully
conduct a retrospective study because as
I mentioned before one size does not fit
all and you'll end up filtering out the
vast majority of potential collaborators
if you hold to firm to any any
superfluous requirements in a study like
this let's go up to the the top left
here so we'll kind of mix it up a bit
I've alluded to this before but I think
it's really important to define not only
your ideal criteria for both samples and
data but also to define what I'll call
your your your minimum requirements on
the second bullet here I've alluded to a
psychology technique that they call foot
in the door there's the foot in the door
technique and there's the door in the
face technique the foot in the door
technique
is you start with a minimal asked to
kind of get your foot in the door and
then you as you get a yes to the first
one you incrementally add additional
requests in the hope of working up to
your ideal with the door in the face
technique it's pretty much the opposite
you start with the ideal and then you
work back from there so in our
experience the foot in the door
technique does tend to work best because
you can get institutions more engaged by
saying this is the minimum criteria that
we need for participation in this but if
you can do more we'd love to to talk
with you about the ideal criteria that
we're shooting for this does create a
bit of a challenge on the back end of
conducting retrospective study in that
when you start sacrificing on your ideal
criteria you do start to limit what you
can do from a publication standpoint and
this can include things like waterfall
charts kaplan-meier curves things of
that nature ideally if you can get as
many ideal criteria as possible you can
produce at least a subset of your
overall population with those types of
charts in such a way that that you can
go ahead and have a publication that's
robust with a a complete reference
population but perhaps just a subset for
for some of those charts let's go down
to the to the bottom left-hand side here
robust documentation this is another
point that I think is really important
to stress with retrospective studies by
and large the institutions that will
participate will be interested they will
certainly be incented by the economics
hopefully the science as well but it's
important to bear in mind that the less
work you ask of these institutions the
more likely they are to respond to the
work that's actually needed to be done
and so in this bullet it really helps to
think through all of the documentation
that an institution could request from
you before you have that conversation so
that immediately following a
teleconference you can go ahead and send
them a document with everything that
they've requested already laid out what
you're doing in in that is you're
reducing the amount of work that they
need to complete themselves and in doing
so you're allowing them to essentially
make their lives a lot easier which will
ultimately make your life easier so the
second bullet on this I think is
important I think in our experience what
you want to do is is you want to provide
some documentation on the study design
on the science on the ideal parameters
for samples on the economics etc you do
want to provide that up front you know
because you have to give potential
collaborators some indication of what it
is you're working on but on the back end
if you start to get into protocols as
you start to get into IRB documentation
as you start to get into sample
preparation documentation and our
experience it's typically better to hold
that back and to distribute that as its
requested if you start off kind of
spending the entire bolus of all this
documentation again the human psychology
element does come into play here you
risk scaring them off from actually
participating with you in the study and
so that's that's where that bad
recommendation comes in finally we'll go
up to the to the top right-hand portion
of the slide practicing your pitch so
the the conversation does take a while
to home you know it's best to do a few
kind of internal will call them dry run
so to speak of your pitch before you
have your first conversation with
someone external with that said you
should really look at your pitch as
living breathing presentation some
messaging you'll probably find yourself
repeating over and over again because
it's effective others you'll you'll just
throw out and you'll you put in
something new from scratch because
either it didn't address a point that
that you've gotten repeated questions on
it was done so in a way that was too
complex for people to understand i mean
there's a wide variety so the second
bullet i have on here i think is really
important to bear in mind keep
experimenting with with different
approaches so that over time you will
find yourself digging into a pretty
comfortable groove in which you have
answers to the most frequent questions
you're presenting the material in a way
that's accessible for the audience to to
receive and and you're addressing most
if not all of the common questions in
the presentation itself so that you can
really then skip ahead to the the
questions that are going to be specific
to an institution so all of this said
you know this this is really our
experience so far with with
retrospective studies they are
incredibly important they are really a
key to enabling precision medicine
because without them it's difficult to
prove the utility of a lot of these
great innovations that we have developed
and so for for everyone kind of
listening to this I would just make
believe that that either when your
approach to participate in the study of
this nature or when you're considering
one yourself I think it's important for
us as an industry to to really try to
work together as best as possible to to
make these things a reality because if
everyone kind of stays in their own silo
if everyone is in
flexible to the potential absolute
requirements of other parties then we'll
continue to exist in this kind of space
where we're not as much research is
getting done that could potentially get
done and that that's really a shame not
only for for the industry but also for
the promises of precision medicine as a
whole and finally my last comment here
this is this is a picture of my daughter
she's about to turn two years old here
in April you know I think one of the
great things about working in this
industry is that you know we really are
working on something that will hopefully
impact our loved ones if not ourselves
and so as I think about you know
challenges like these they're very
tactical but at the same time I I'm
always considering how success at very
tactical things like obtaining samples
for a retrospective study will
ultimately lead to the breakthroughs
that could potentially save the lives of
those we love and what could be more
important than that I thank you for the
time i'm going to go ahead and hand it
back off now and i welcome your
questions thank you
Thank You mr. Club booster for that
informative presentation quick reminder
for our audience on how to submit
questions simply type them in the Q&A
box sounds by clicking on the green Q&A
button at the lower left in the
presentation window mr. occlusive will
answer as many questions as time permits
without hesitation what's hop in and a
guitar first question of the day this
question asks why does the attrition
rate for sample tend to be so high yeah
that's a great question I mean I you
would think that identifying the
potential cases I mean let's just say
for example in a retrospective study
you're looking for patients that have
been treated with a particular drug who
are above 18 years old and have not had
you know their first dose of the drug
yet for the sample you would think that
that you know close to a hundred percent
of of those samples would be available
the challenge is really when you get
into two things one is the data
requirements and secondly is the samples
so even though pharmacy records at an
institution may indicate you know let's
say 400 patients have been treated with
with a particular drug once you go in
and you say well who actually has
samples that can be pulled and analyzed
you're probably going to have a pretty
significant drop-off just at that point
and that could be because the initial
sample was was very small such as a fine
needle aspirate or it could just be
because you know they they sent the
sample off somewhere else for analysis
it may be with another lab there are
whole host of reasons why why that can
happen that's really the first reason
the second reason is around the data
requirements
as you start looking at who has a
valuable scans for doing things like
waterfall plots as you start looking at
outcomes data institutions you know
maybe a second opinion institution so
they may not have actually followed up
with that patient after the initial
treatment you know in other cases they
may have you know simply not tracked
that person after they stopped coming in
even if they were in a local setting so
so you do tend to see a wide variety of
reasons why the attrition rate is so
high and really what it is it's a
compounding factor across all those
different variables that leads to that
eighty percent plus attrition rate
[Music]
thank you so much for that answer our
second question of the day asked how is
your organization dealing with these
challenges to advanced precision
medicine yeah thnkx that's a great
question the biggest thing i think we're
trying to do and i would recommend this
to everyone trying to do one of these
studies with very high attrition rates
with a variety of different challenges
with different types of institutions my
boss likes to say sometimes you've got
to try to get as many shots on goal this
is a hockey analogy we're based in
Buffalo so that's probably appropriate
you try to get as many shots on goal as
you can even if you're your actual let's
call it a field goal percentage in
basketball parlance even if it isn't
terribly high if you have a lot of shots
on goal if you have a lot of lines in
the water to use a fishing analogy the
hope is that you'll get at least you
know some percentage of those to
actually come through and so what we've
done is we've really tried to cast this
why the net is possible to be able to
get as many institutions into the funnel
as we can and then we kind of let this
natural attrition process take place and
we get the institutions that we have as
we get all the way through
thank you for that answer it looks like
we have one final question of the day in
this question asked what are the typical
prices on a per sample basis in your
experience yeah that's that's a good
question as well and unfortunately it's
it's highly highly variable so as I
mentioned in the presentation typical
pharmaceutical rates per sample tend to
be in kind of the five to ten thousand
dollar range for a retrospective study
out I'll tell you we started offering
about three hundred dollars per sample
hoping that that would be enough it
turns out it really wasn't what we tend
to find is that most institutions are
more comfortable in kind of the 750 to
$1,500 range per sample one thing to
bear in mind with this is that some
institutions are actually either going
outside of their own four walls to get
this work done or there's some sort of
pitch and catch internally within the
institution where one department has to
send funds to another department to get
this type of work done and so in a lot
of cases it's not necessarily greed of
the institution that's driving the price
although there is certainly a little bit
of that but it does tend to be related
to the rates that are standard either
within the institution that you're
working with or with their external
partners so we found generally that for
a retrospective study where it's a
non-interventional project somewhere in
the 750 to $1,500 range tends to be
enough to to to get most institutions
over the line
I would like to once the gamma thank mr.
Cletus for his presentation today it was
truly enjoyable in very informative I'd
also like to make the audience for
joining us today in lab report based
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on demand through May 2017
libraries will alert you via email when
it is available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event this is christina from la
cruz and we'll see you here next time
goodbye